CROOKES RESPONDED SHE WOULD LIKE
THE SECURITY CAMERA FOOTAGE
RELEASED.
TONIGHT WE BEGIN A THREE-PART
REGULATION NATION SERIES BY
LOOKING AT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S ROLLBACK OF
MANY EDUCATION DEPARTMENT
POLICIES.
CORRESPONDENT DOUG McKELWAY
TELLS US THERE'S A LOT OF RED
TAPE TO CUT THROUGH.
>> I AM CHALLENGING MY CABINET
TO FIND AND REMOVE EVERY SINGLE
OUTDATED, UNLAWFUL, EXCESSIVE
REGULATION CURRENTLY ON THE
BOOKS.
>> FEW FEDERAL AGENCIES IMPOSE
GREATER BUREAUCRATIC BURDENS
THAN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, CREATED BY
PRESIDENT CARTER IN 1979.
EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES" AT THE
TIME EDITORIALIZED AGAINST IT
SANG EDUCATION WILL "CONTINUE TO
DO BETTER WITHOUT A CENTRAL
BUREAUCRACY."
MORE THAN 30 YEARS LATER, THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGED EDUCATION
ESPECIALLY HIGHER EDUCATION.
SINCE 1996, COLLEGE TUITION HAS
SKYROCKETED 200% AND     END.
WE HAVE NOT JUST MORE
ADMINISTRATORS AND FACULTY.
THERE ARE MORE ADMINISTRATORS
THAN OUR PERSONNEL AND
UNIVERSITIES TEACHING, RESEARCH.
THEY ARE ALL GETTING PAY DECENT
SALARIES.
COSTS GO WHALE.
>> GRADUATION RATES HAVE
DECLINED.
59% AMONG STUDENTS SEEKING A
FOUR-YEAR DEGREE.
STUDENT LOAN DEFAULT ARE
SOARING, AND ISSUE THE
ADMINISTRATION TRY TO TACKLE
WHEN IT PROPOSED CAPPING
PAYMENTS.
>> TO US IN THE AMERICAN PUBLIC,
REGULATIONS ARE THE PUBLIC
PROTECTIONS WE DEPEND ON.
>> EDUCATION SECRETARY BETSY
DeVOS HAS BEEN RESCINDING
FEDERAL MANDATES AND HAS TRIED
TO TACKLE THE ISSUE IN LOWER
EDUCATION.
GONE UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION: MICHELLE OBAMA'S
SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAM.
CHOCOLATE MILK IS BACK.
ALSO GONE ACCOUNTABILITY
PROGRAMS LIKE NO CHILD LEFT
BEHIND AND THE RACE TO THE TOP.
MOST CONTROVERSIAL, BETSY
DeVOS HAS RECALLED TITLE IX
STANDARDS FOR SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
>> WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF THE
"ME TOO" MOMENT.
PEOPLE ARE PAYING ATTENTION TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
>> STUDENTS ARE SUING AND